hi and welcome back to sarahs music it's
Christmas time here in Berlin and for
many Christmas wouldn't be Christmas
without a visit to tchaikovsky's ballet
The Nutcracker for me the Nutcracker
captures perfectly the spirit of
Christmas we have a big family party we
have a battle between mice and toy
soldiers we have the Sugar Plum Fairy
and of course we also have the dancing
snowflakes
today we're visiting the berlin state
ballet company at the Deutsche oppa
where they're in final rehearsals for
this season's opening night of the
Nutcracker this one of the traditional
production is for and about children and
it had its premiere here in Berlin in
2013
frida clara moskowitz are never free
deliver claw fighters Katie's of our own
tightness kanaka yeah it is the key test
me so cans is missing whose leg order
like one problem is in aligning our
children de Jenkins on me don't even
discuss and others pretty sure the
Pokemon now its image everything and
interruption deepest to Oscar inform
Clara to Thompson yeah as I step I know
flowers fires a quiche Manzo on daddy
I'm not a closely grouped on and it's
and visa declare at Hanson will say I
had a nice apartment on um yeah and and
most money in da mata de su Keenan was
just a few anxiety memos and the south
Here I am standing to burn on then
customer happens to Alice Waters what is
in town from dear as a na'vi incite
rebellion by owns a necklace and a sugar
fijian vices and frost the ski on a
tenth of them would wish to the mall
octi of axonal Clara Thompson let the
every special need a tenser than way
it's a centrist its tenth my gosh
amusing little philosophy on the cipher
ethnic i bizarra terms Oh Sofia
this Nutcracker is closely based on the
original production from 1856 by marius
petipa and Lev Ivanov for the Mariinsky
Theatre in st. Petersburg it was
researched and restage for berlin by
vasily Medvedev and Yuri bellaca who
were here in Berlin preparing the
company for the seasons performances
Yuri vasilis pasiva Bolshoi thank you
for coming to talk to me this is a
beautiful beautiful production and I
know that you based it very much on the
original production the choreography
foreign Petipa is it very important to
you both as choreographers to stay to
the into this day this traditional way
in the Nutcracker no priests yamaha
chili gels cusco but a must vladimir
malikov kotori glacial geology to
produces estas ballot on in Macatawa
shabnam a spectacular acog dated ballot
was valid theory keturah people agree to
chino judias aprecio vetti story at
natalka gofman goffman anushka miss da
latest telugu RPG / 11 Fanny Brice's
adaptive in history Giovanna Alexander
Duma Couture sdl I took mr. evil evil
Japanese e bullied lady t vitamin nurse
Webber Paul na ETO night a spectacle
pierwszy spectacle Couture video
Tchaikovsky nest EBT cards amicus to me
debatable ballys kaskin your your
choreography includes many more children
than in other productions there were
hundreds of children on the stage this
is that a big challenge as a
choreographer to to include so many
children such cool a colligative awesome
she said the voice visit voice in the
city's Anitra's resnick classif
my nano above a spittin estos dias que
queda bliss animal in cable is Anita
spectacular miskovsky akademi Lee
Academy began away kaboom visitor so
partially in height a little nudge Tobin
are some spectacular busy global is
Anita GT to put a quibble spectacular
glia CC me students an apology Disick
risata y kappa s do gusta la época del
voto discussion paratus coba lihat
quibble spectacle pre in karate quibble
resist bullet I think it's wonderful
because you're inspired when the
children go to the ballet to watch it
they see other children dancing and it's
easy they think oh I want to do this so
maybe you are inspiring the next
generation of dancers with your
production it will be nice and daughters
83 go the dojo Villanova clarino we
freed xenovia mushky novia Draghi
personal religious coquina puja trono de
volta progestin spectacular a
conditional in english college in
political Daniel Chester with revenues
of Jerusalem if the co-production linear
Basha practica Italy danisha career
condition eight which is normal Thank
You spasiba borrow a random toy toy toy
for the for the first performance of
this this year if you make is possible
we've been invited to film here in the
wings what an exclusive view it's
exciting to watch the ballet from here
together with all the mice in the
snowflakes
bye
can I see nimisha thank you for coming
to talk to us after your really tiring
rehearsal it's a lot of energy you need
to dance these rules I think it's
wonderful that this production is so
traditional do you think it's it's
important for them for if a child was
seeing Nutcracker for the first time
would you wish for them to see a
production like this one I think so I
think they will enjoy much more to see a
real snowflakes like he say in the
forest and but it's also interesting
because children see children playing so
they can also it's really nice also
atmosphere for children because you know
when the growing up person explained the
story of Nutcracker it's one thing but
when the children see children playing
it's small at the same level they're you
know they're and more on the same wave
with each other so it's a real fairy
tale magic
and talking about the ballet part of it
the technical part of it you have to
jump around a lot in this production
it's really i mean it's it's i love i
love those well it's really tough
because it's also pure classic as well
and of course there it's like they put
everything all the classical and
technical stuff which you have to do and
you have to do it clean you have to do
it like the way it's supposed to be and
they're really asking for it because
they also have a very good school and
you've really asked you to pull out
everything thank you so much for talking
to me both and it's hard work sitting on
the floor I thought it was a good idea
that's all from Sarah's music for today
the whole Sarah's music team wishes you
a Merry Christmas and a music-filled New
Year by
you
so for today's horn challenge who should
I ask hmm Santa of course will you play
the horn for us oh thank you